at the peak how many total employees did
you guys have at your Peak I think it
was over sixty thousand over sixty
thousand employees okay and I I remember
uh uh I can't tell you how many of the
employees that were people I recruited
to the insurance industry whom worked
there to tell you they loved working for
the company would be an understatement
to tell you they loved working for the
when I'm telling you like they loved it
I'm telling you they loved it and they
were guys like one of the things you
guys were known for uh the the bank
managers were actually making real money
so people got paid actually pretty well
it's not like people weren't getting
paid uh you paid better than some of the
other guys did and you took care of your
guys and they were evangelists going
around talking about how great wama was
to the point where they believed in you
and the company so much that they put
100 their 401K stocks into WAMU they
were all like no I'm just doing WAMU
because this thing's going I'm gonna
Bank on this long term many of them did
not all of them but a lot of them didn't
by the way
there is a um you know that's a sign of
believing in the company you're a part
of there's a lot of people that put all
their eggs in one basket many people
became wealthy did it that way now
sometimes if it doesn't go your way
that's also the story that we read about
but for me when I'm when I'm when I'm
going through this and I'm hearing these
stories with you know uh where you were
at is there ever where you feel like as
the CEO at the top you know the balance
between because look capitalism is run
off of a greed and not greed in a
negative way Milton Friedman was
unfilled down to you and he says well
don't you think you guys are driven by
counters as a capital and I said what
Phil you think you're not greedy you
think I'm the only one greedy you don't
think people in the government are
greedy like what makes you think the
saint out there that's not driven by
agree like introduce me to that person
not like he's talking about Ralph Nader
at that time this was 40 years ago when
the best interviews I saw but all of us
want a little bit more we want to win
right we want to go out there and win
and we're all capitalists here we're big
proponents of capitalism myself I
escaped you around to come here because
capitalism changed my life however what
do you think is the right balance
between
the dry Factor the hey we can do more we
can do more let's get one more one more
billion customer let's get 10 more
million 10 million more customers let's
do this and then regulation to balance
both and then having a leader that's
able to see some Trends to say guys
we're kind of going on the deep end here
that we can kind of screw this thing up
what do you think is the balance between
us the doers the entrepreneurs the
creators the disruptors the competitors
versus The Regulators that are out there
saying maybe maybe we need a little bit
of Regulation with this product here
maybe we need to kind of take a look at
this what what role you think these two
play well I think of course in banking
it's a pretty highly regulated business
uh and um and I think we we had you know
for decades really good relationships
with the regulators and we would have
those discussions every meeting about
where is that balance between uh trying
to hit Financial objectives that we
thought were were good and at the same
time maintaining a safe uh safe profile
and and one of the things I did is we
had The Regulators attend every one of
our quarterly meetings where we would
lay out the entire strategic plan what
the balance was between growth and what
it was for risk management and the like
and they bought off on all those and uh
and again the bank had always been in
banking you have a numerical rating of
one to five called a camel's rating and
we were for years and years and years a
a solid two rating and I if in leading
into the financial crisis they even gave
us uh a uh in 2007 their exam findings
to the board I'll remember the meeting
they said you know you are a two rating
again this year but we're going to
really tell you it's a two plus rating
it's the best you've ever been and we're
increasing your liquidity rating to a
one which is the highest in the industry
well 12 months later the financial
crisis hits because of all those things
like that and all of a sudden they are
all panicked and uh liquidity is what
ultimately was the major challenge for
Washington Mutual so you go from being a
number one rated to saying gosh this is
the most uh vulnerable part of what we
have but I think just getting back to it
I think that having a good balance
dialogue we always tried to have it you
know in a normal course of business we
would typically grow uh I'll say roughly
10 percent a year sometimes a little
less than that our major growth beyond
that just came from when there were some
very opportunistic Acquisitions uh like
when we entered Californian were able to
become a major player player there and
we're able to get some Acquisitions on
great terms and great you know that were
encouraged to us by the by The
Regulators in fact uh so we we did have
that very strong long-term growth but uh
but we were mostly interested in uh
being sure we had a balanced scorecard
so everybody got paid on a balanced
scorecard it was never just on uh
commissions it was always balanced out
with the loan quality it was balanced
out with efficiency ratios all that kind
of stuff to uh to try to be sure you're
growing a great business for the long
term
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]